[Musique]
dans le quartier kensington à toronto la
feuille de cannabis fait partie du décor
et laisse l'epasa est différent
à la sortie d'un dispensaire illégale du
jeune homme nous montrent leurs achats
en pleine rue le cannabis fait partie de
leur vie pour eux il est banal voire
inoffensifs la fin tous mes amis
conduisent après avoir fumé de la
marijuana raconte jeffrey saut presque
tous mes collègues de travail le fonds
ajoute son ami quelques pas plus loin
d'autres passante même histoire
j'ai une amie qui croient vraiment être
une meilleure conductrice lorsqu'elle
est gelée raconte cette jeune femme
c'est petit
cette perception a de quoi étonner mais
semble répandue dans une enquête récente
5 % d'élèves canadien de niveau
secondaire ont affirmé avoir déjà
conduit peu de temps après avoir fumé du
cannabis et 15 % rapporte avoir été à
bord d'un véhicule conduit par une
personne ayant consommé
c'est dangereux de penser que le
cannabis au volant et sécuritaire selon
ce scientifique
à l'aide de ce simulateur il étudie les
effets de la marijuana sur la conduite
automobile
des dizaines de participants en ont
consommé avant de s'engager sur une
route virtuel
le conducteur doit composer avec des
imprévus robotman et son équipe observe
tous les détails leur travail n'est pas
terminé mais les études réalisées par
les autres chercheurs sont claires la
consommation de cannabis peut nuire à
plusieurs fonctions essentielles
lorsqu'on est derrière le volant comme
le temps de réaction
la constance de la vitesse ou la
capacité à rester dans sa voix pour
risque d'être impliqué dans une
collision sont beaucoup plus élevés
[Musique]
hector ne vois pas du tout les choses de
la même façon si vous vous sentez bien
je ne vois pas de problème à fumer y
conduit nous avons fait écouter ses
commentaires à celui qui pilote le
dossier de la légalisation du cannabis
pour le gouvernement trudeau
vous êtes mal informé
on vous a menti voudrais leur répondre
l'ancien chef de police
il y a trente ou quarante ans les
canadiens avaient la même attitude par
rapport à l'alcool fait il remarquer
pour lui seules les études scientifiques
et l'éducation publique peuvent changer
les mentalités pays peut changer en un
instant ne conduit pas gelé 1 mais les
campagnes actuelles ratent leur cible
selon cette criminologue
elle croit qu'il faut plutôt outiller
les consommateurs pour qu'ils
reconnaissent les signes de facultés
affaiblies comment je vais vérifier que
je n'ai facultés affaiblies ou non et
ceci ne peut se faire qu'avec des tests
de réflexes qui compte sur lesquels on
pourra les ducs est dire si t'es pas
capable de réussir ces tests mais je
pense que t'as pas les réflexes
nécessaires pour conduire
il ne faut pas attendre au mois de
juillet pour un jury il s'offre à
trouver un message crédible parce
qu'elle est déjà de nombreux conducteurs
sur les routes qui conduisent après
avoir consommé du cannabis
[Musique]
combien de temps faudra-t-il pour
changer les comportements pour l'alcool
il a fallu des décennies famille et pour
hector l'alcool et la route ne font pas
bon ménage il cannabis produit du jeu
certainement que je conduirai après
avoir fumé mais boire et conduire jamais